la politique encore en loir et cher je
vous le disais en titre cette annonce
qui a pris tout le monde de court
nicolas perruchot mettra fin à sa
carrière politique à la fin de son
mandat de président du département sans
doute en juin dans les colonnes de la nr
et dit vouloir privilégier sa famille et
dénoncent un climat délétère après
l'épisode de l'enregistrement pirate
les précisions d'hélène s'appelait
nicolas perruchot l'actuel président du
conseil départemental de loir et cher va
se retirer de la vie politique
c'est en tout cas ce qu'il annonce dans
les colonnes de la nouvelle république
ce lundi l'élu ne briguera pas de
nouveau mandat une fois le sien terminer
en juin prochain
c'est un nouvel article paru dans le
canard enchaîné le 30 décembre dernier
qui aurait été l'élément déclencheur
on y apprend que l'élu les républicains
auraient obtenu un prêt conséquent par
rapport à ses revenus pour se faire
construire une villa de plus d'un
million en corse pour ses détracteurs
cette nouvelle affaire illustre le
manque d'exemplarité de l'élu je suis
surpris de quelqu'un qui se retire de la
vie politique mais qui reste en poste
ça me paraît être une décision plus
assez ambigu ambivalente de notre
président le conseil départemental
j'ai l'impression qu'à chaque fois qu'il
ya une affaire finalement il crée lui
même une autre affaire dans la dernière
sur sa ville à dire qu'il va augmenter
ses indemnités pour pouvoir payer son
logement en avant la situation accells
actuelle cesser complètement inaudible
de la part de la population c'est même
insupportable
comment ne pas réaliser qu'un fossé se
creuse ensuite avec les citoyens quand
on agit de la sorte
du côté de ses partisans saluent son
professionnalisme et sa maîtrise des
dossiers
marie hélène millet du modem le connaît
depuis une vingtaine d'années ensemble
ils ont été élus à la mairie blois en
2001 c'est un homme je pense très actif
qui connaît parfaitement bien ses
dossiers
c'est un très gros travailleur il est il
est au département il est tout le temps
et je pense que c'est quelqu'un qui est
vraiment reconnu pour ça pour avoir
vraiment travailler avec efficacité
c'est dommage oui ce sera une perte
parce que oui mais je pense que j'espère
que nous retrouverons quelqu'un
quelqu'un d'autre mais bon c'est vrai
que c'est un arrêt c'est un arrêt brutal
avant les prochaines élections
départementales nicolas perruchot va
donc avoir le temps d'organiser sa
succession et de défendre son bilan
contactée pour les besoins de ce
reportage le principal intéressé n'a pas
souhaité répondre à nos questions